a lot of us spend a lot of time
academically and it's important to take
time and pursue things that we enjoy
outside of the classroom so kiltie been
really gave me that outlet to do so
we're really just here to enjoy
ourselves and make music and make other
people laugh and mostly make ourselves
laugh I partly chose Carnegie Mellon
because it has a marching band that I
could be in but not spend you know 12
hours a day being in I heard there was a
non major
marching band on campus they wore kilts
thought that was a little odd but I
thought I'd go with it I got to play fun
music with cool people kind of nerdy
people I got to listen to mr. Gerlach
and he gets to show us how to play music
well teaching us Kilty is one of my
favorite things because it's like
totally non-academic it's low pressure
low stress the point is to have fun and
just enjoy yourself and play music and
have a good time I have football games
we do interesting things like if we see
a helicopter in the air we say holy crap
it's a helicopter and stuff like that
they're just weird quirks we embrace and
we really enjoy cote has its own hat but
we don't really wear them often instead
people can pick their own cool had an
awesome band and everyone should
participate we're all here because we
love it and we want to have fun I would
say that it's a great way to continue to
play your instrument if you played in
high school
we're not that weird no auditions
requires a lot of fun be prepared for a
lot of puns and just be ready to expect
the unexpected with GUILTY been honestly
[Music]